the 76ers suspending ben simmons the
good thing about it though ernie they
only suspend him for one day so he'll be
in a much better altitude by thursday so
here's the yeah
here's the here's the situation now this
this video is from yesterday from monday
he was he was at practice with the
sixers he did more than just stand there
they had to stop according to whom yeah
hey chase cause i've seen the video but
here you're looking at the at the end of
the workout and so he's just kind of
like dribbling the ball behind the team
as they gather and put their hands in
and okay there's nothing wrong with that
we don't know what would have happened
well kenny he had a cell phone in his
pocket but i'm talking about this i'm
just saying when the coach is talking it
looks a little looks a little disengaged
i mean
i could point out somebody else in that
video
they're not talking to doc rivers or
listening to doc anymore so um
it only got uh worse today because uh he
was kicked out of practice by doc rivers
uh when he refused to uh
take part in the drill and doc said that
was enough and said get out um so he bet
about friday though they played uh they
played friday he only kicked him out for
one yeah so he will not go to new
orleans and play in the open so you are
laughing about this at this point
it's just a joke yeah it's a joke it's
stupid and it's silly uh ben
first of all is everybody's fault ben
simmons deserves number one to blame
because when you when people ask you to
be a better basketball player and
they're paying you 35 40 million that's
a very fair thing
the sixers deserve some blame because
they already let this guy not improve
and get one coach fired so they deserve
some blame for that they threw brett
brown under the bus
and the third thing is doc rivers last
year we had him on there you guys want
me to take ben simmons out the game yeah
we do if he's just gonna stand around
and not shoot the basketball yes we do
so there's plenty of blame to go around
but the number one blame
goes with ben simmons
kenny shaq
your coach
your mom and dad
you should want to be a better
basketball player because that's your
profession that's your job your coach is
important your mom and dad's important
but i wanted to be a great basketball
player